>> Tucker: FACEBOOK CEO
MARK ZUCKERBERG SPENT ANOTHER
ACTION-PACKED DAY ON
CAPITOL HILL TODAY TAKING
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMERCE
COMMITTEE.
DURING THE HEARING, HE WAS
PRESSED ON WHETHER FACEBOOK'S
ACTIONS AMOUNT TO CENSORSHIP.
>> DO YOU MANIPULATE YOUR
ALGORITHMS TO CENSOR SPEECH?
>> CONGRESSWOMAN, WE DON'T THINK
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING AS A
CENTERING SPEECH.
THERE ARE TYPES OF CONTENT LIKE
TERRORISM THAT I THINK WE ALL
AGREE WE DO NOT WANT TO HAVE ON
OUR SERVICE, SO WE BUILD SYSTEMS
THAT CAN IDENTIFY THOSE AND CAN
REMOVE THAT CONTENT AND WE ARE
VERY PROUD OF THAT WORK.
>> LET ME TOYS OF THE GREAT NOW.
DIAMOND AND SILK IS NOT
TERRORISM.
>> Tucker: HERE'S AN EXAMPLE,
ERIC NESBITT AS REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE IN THE STATE OF
MICHIGAN.
HIS ONLINE CAMPAIGN ANNOUNCEMENT
WAS RECENTLY REJECTED BY
FACEBOOK CONTAINING WHAT THEY
CALLED "SHOCKING AND
DISRESPECTFUL MATERIAL."
FACEBOOK NOW SAYS THAT REJECTION
WAS A MISTAKE.
ERIC NESBITT TOWARDS US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
WHAT EXACTLY ABOUT YOUR
ANNOUNCEMENT WAS DETERMINED BY
FACEBOOK AS DISRESPECTFUL OR
SHOCKING?
>> I'M STILL TRYING TO FIGURE
THAT OUT.
I WAS ANNOUNCING MY CANDIDACY
FOR THE STATE SENATE LAST WEEK
IN WESTERN MICHIGAN.
TALKED ABOUT LOWERING TAXES AND
AUTO INSURANCE RATES AND
PROTECTING OUR SECOND AMENDED
RIGHTS.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU'VE GOT TO
DEFENDING THE UNBORN AND THE
SECOND AMENDMENT, YOU DON'T
THINK THAT'S SHOCKING?
>> MAY BE BANNING CENTURY CITIES
AND I HAD A PICTURE OF A FEW
VETERANS THAT I WAS TALKING TO
ALSO.
I ANNOUNCED IT LAST WEEK AND I
WANTED TO BOOST THE AD ON FRIDAY
AND I STARTED TO PUT THAT BOOST
IN AND IT USUALLY TAKES A FEW
HOURS FOR THEM TO APPROVE IT.
I GOT HOME AROUND 6:00 ON FRIDAY
NIGHT AND THAT'S WHEN THEY SENT
ME THAT MESSAGE SAYING THAT
YOU'RE NOT FOLLOWING OUR
ADVERTISING POLICIES.
I WAS KIND OF TAKEN ABACK
BECAUSE I SPENT A FEW HUNDRED
DOLLARS TRYING TO GET INTO
COUNTIES FROM WHERE I LIVE.
I FIGURED I'LL ASK MY FACEBOOK
AUDIENCE WHETHER FACEBOOK IS
CENSORING.
I THINK THE ANSWER CAME AND WAS
PRETTY OPEN FOR MY FOLLOWERS.
>> Tucker: FACEBOOK SAYS IT'S
A MISTAKE, DO YOU THINK THIS
KIND OF THING HAPPENS TO
DEMOCRATS RUNNING FOR STATE
SENATE SEAT?
>> I HAVEN'T HEARD ABOUT THIS ON
ANY RECORD.
I WAS NAMED A CONSERVATIVE
REFORMER, SO I CONTINUE TO GET
OUT THERE.
IT'S PRETTY FRUSTRATED WHEN
YOU'RE RUNNING A MODERN
CAMPAIGN, YOU'VE GOT TO BE ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, YOU HAVE TO BE ON
THE INTERNET TO BE ABLE TO
BROADCAST.
EVERY COMPANY KNOWS WHETHER
THEY'VE BEEN THE TARGET FOR A
TWITTER STORM OR FACEBOOK,
YOU'VE GOT TO RESPOND QUICKLY.
IF THIS MEANS 78 HOURS, LIBERALS
ARE ABLE TO RESPOND VERY
QUICKLY.
I THINK IT'S VERY TROUBLING.
SENATOR CRUZ REALLY HIT THE NAIL
ON ITS HEAD YESTERDAY DURING THE
HEARING, .
>> Tucker: IT'S A MASSIVE